Hi Michael.
>> Hey Charles. How's it going?
>> It is going quite well. Thank you very
much for asking. How are things going with you?
>> I can't complain because I've been barred by a, a judge.
>> [LAUGH] I'm pretty sure you can still complain. Complaining is a
fine art that requires lots of practice. Guess what we're going to do today?
>> I'm reading decision making and
reinforcement learning which is very exciting.
>> It is.
>> Except the hyphen.
>> Except for the hyphen?
>> Yeah the hyphens wrong.
>> Why?
>> because
it's not decision dash making.
>> You're right. I normally don't do that
but people always want to put a dash
so what I'm going to do is for your
Michael. Just for you. I'm going to remove the dash.
>> Thank you.
>> And I'm going to put it over here where it belongs.
>> [LAUGH] No. There. Well, Michael, this is
the first of our discussions on the last
mini course of machine learning, Reinforcement Learning, which
I believe you know a little bit about.
>> I
am very interested in Reinforcement Learning.
>> Excellent. So I'm just going to do
a little bit of background. It's going to
be relatively short and straight forward. We're
going to do a couple of quizzes, because
I know how much you like quizzes. And then we're just going to go back
and forth and see what we get to learn about Reinforcement Learning. Sound good?
>> Excellent.
>> Excellent, okay so, let's get started.